the probability of winning the Powerball
lottery is one in 175 million two
hundred twenty three thousand five
hundred eleven I'm assuming this is even
if this is when you buy a Powerball
lottery ticket this is a probability
then they tell us the probability of
becoming a billionaire in the United
States is zero point zero zero zero zero
zero one which is more likely and I
assume this is like saying if you were
to randomly select a person at birth
what is the probability that that person
is going to become a billionaire and
that's this number right over here and
just looking at this it's kind of hard
to compare so let me try to write this
second number this decimal as a fraction
and that we might be able to make more
of a direct comparison so zero point and
let's see we have five zeroes one two
three four five and then we have a one
and so let's just think about what place
that one is in this is in the tenths
place
that's the tenths place that's the
hundredths place
that's the thousands place that's the
ten thousandths place and that's the
hundred thousandths place and this right
over here is the millions place so this
one little remember represents one
millionth so this is the exact same
thing this is equivalent to 1 over 1
million this is one millionth this is
one million this is one 775 million two
hundred twenty-three thousand five
hundred and eleven so this is a this
whole thing this whole expression this
whole expression here is a much smaller
value with the same numerator we have a
one in both cases this denominator is
much larger so this entire fraction is
much much smaller actually by roughly a
factor of 175 much smaller this is
roughly 1 over 175 million this is 1
over a million so which is more likely
which is more likely if you were to pick
a random person who bought a lottery
ticket and the probability of them
winning the Powerball lottery or if you
were to pick a random person and you say
the probability of them becoming a
billionaire it's actually far more
likely roughly 175 times more likely
that that person could become a
a billionaire so much more likely
becoming a billionaire